ladies and gentlemen Robert
Spencer I'm very glad to be here today
to be able
to for probably the first time ever
bring you some good news and that is
that Hillary Clinton is running for
president of the United
States and this is of course the best
gift that the Republican party has
received in
ages but there is of course in a serious
uh uh in a very serious way the
possibility that we have to entertain
that she could really be the next
president and it is with that in mind
that I think that it is important to
recall today some of the aspects of her
record that are very little
discussed we all know about Benghazi we
all know that the Obama Administration
now was apprised that it was an Al-Qaeda
attack from the beginning and that they
refused and ignored repeated calls for
help and left the Ambassador Chris
Stevens and his colleagues to be killed
we know all that but there's
more we know that the Obama
Administration immediately blamed a
video about
Muhammad and that that video then became
the Touchstone for riots and killings
around the Islamic world with innocent
people being killed because of this
video what is less known is that that
video itself had 17 views on YouTube at
the time when the Obama Administration
attributed the attacks in Benghazi to
it and that nobody in other words had
heard of it nobody knew that this video
existed not only that there millions of
things on YouTube and many many hundreds
of thousands I would guess
videos attacking various aspects of
Islam the Quran Muhammad many of who
many of which have many many thousands
and even millions of
views so what is it that happened that
the Obama Administration and in
particular the Secretary of State
Hillary Clinton fastened on this one
video in order to attribute the attack
on Chris Stevens and his colleagues to
it what it was was I think the
culmination of a yearslong effort by
Hillary Clinton and the Obama
Administration in general to acques to a
concerted campaign to curtail the
freedom of
speech this is what I mean the
organization of Islamic cooperation is
57 Muslim governments around the world
56 Nations and the Palestinian Authority
since the collapse of the Soviet block
it is the largest voting block at the
United
Nations and from 1999 to 2010 every year
they introduced a resolution at the UN
calling for the criminalization of
incitement to religious
hatred and this is where it becomes very
difficult nobody's in favor of hatred
nobody's in favor of uh mocking
somebody's uh sacred beliefs and so on
but the fact is that in Islam you recall
as our president has told us the future
must not belong to those who slander the
prophet of
Islam this very important point about
that is this in Islamic law slander is
not telling lies about
somebody slander is telling truths about
somebody that they don't want known that
is as it is defined in Islamic law
books so the organization of Islamic
cooperation is trying to criminalize
incitement to religious hatred by that
they mean honest investigations of the
motives and goals of jihad terrorists
they want to foreclose on the
possibility that counterterror analysts
can study what the jihadis believe and
why they are doing what they're doing
because they say that would be
incitement to religious hatred it will
make people dislike
Muslims because if you look into what
the jihadis are doing why they are doing
it what their stated motives and goals
are it all goes back to Islam and the
Quran and
Muhammad so the organization of Islamic
cooperation in other words has been
trying year after year after year at the
UN to make it a criminal offense and to
compel western states to make it a
criminal offense to discuss openly what
the jihadis believe and why they are
doing what they're
doing which would of course leave a free
hand to the jihadis they would be able
to do whatever they wanted unopposed
without us being able to say a word in
opposition to them and we would be
transgressing against the first dictum
of warfare know your
enemy year after year after year they
did this and the Bush Administration
would vote against it and that was the
end of
it
2011 they changed the wording a little
bit softened it a little bit but it was
essentially the same thing and Hillary
Clinton and the Obama Administration
signed on to
it and not only that but in December
2011 ecad nanu the Secretary General of
the organization of Islamic cooperation
came to Washington and had a 3-day
meeting with Hillary
Clinton it was closed door nobody knows
what they talked about nobody knows what
they did but for 3 days they
met after this resolution had been
passed at the UN which was essentially a
resolution in which the United States
government for the first time in history
went on record as opposing the United
States
Constitution because in saying that the
that certain acts certain speech certain
things people say ought to be
criminalized that's saying we're against
the First
Amendment then fast forward back to
Benghazi nine months after the closed
door meeting with e madini
Sonu Hillary Clinton is at a White House
reception for the survivors the
relatives of the people who were killed
at Benghazi and she went up to the
father of one of the men who was killed
and she said we're going to have that
filmmaker her arrested and
prosecuted and she did and he was served
a year in prison now we all heard and
for all I know it may even be true even
though it was in the New York Times that
this filmmaker had a dodgy reputation
and had a criminal record and he was on
probation and one of the terms of his
probation was he couldn't go on the
internet and so it was taken as a
violation of his probation that the
video was on YouTube now of course the
obvious question is well maybe he got
somebody else to put it
up maybe he had nothing to do with going
on the internet and putting it up but
this was never asked because it was
inconvenient he was put into jail for
violation of probation now let me ask
you this if I went into certain areas of
Los Angeles and walked down the
street how many violators of probation
do you think I might pass
by and how many of them would be walking
free even though they had violated
probation in a far more serious manner
than putting a video on
YouTube and yet this one was singled out
and put in prison after Hillary Clinton
said that was exactly what was going to
happen he became the first political
prisoner in the United States history he
was in prison make no mistake he was in
prison not for his probation violation
he was in prison because he transgressed
against Islamic law
because he disliked Islam and Muhammad
he was in prison in other words for his
opinions which makes him a political
prisoner in the United States it is
illegal to have political Prisoners the
first amendment makes it impossible or
makes it it should be impossible unless
you have a political leader as
unscrupulous as Hillary Clinton and a
media as dishonest as the mainstream
media is
today but the fact is that in the United
States it is not illegal to dislike
Islam the Quran and Muhammad it is not
illegal to dislike Christianity it is
not illegal to dislike any belief system
that you
want it is not illegal to say that some
system of ideas is bad for people and I
oppose it and people have done that
throughout history the reason why as a
matter of fact that is legal in the
United States is because the founding
fathers knew that the king and the
political establishment in Britain would
rule their own opinions out of the realm
of acceptable discourse and imprison
them for their opinions and that the
freedom of speech was therefore the
foundation of a free society that had to
be among the first in the Bill of Rights
because it was the Cornerstone of all
our other
freedoms
now Hillary
Clinton had the filmmaker arrested and
prosecuted it's not illegal in America
law to have opinions that are
unacceptable to the political Elites but
it is illegal in Islamic law as the
organization of Islamic cooperation has
been pursuing all these years it is
illegal in Islamic law for non-muslims
to criticize Islam to denigrate Muhammad
to say that the Quran is a farago any of
these things are outside the bounds of
what is acceptable and are indeed death
penalty
offenses so you could at least I suppose
praise Hillary for her moderation and
that she didn't have the filmmaker
killed but the fact is that in
imprisoning him and in saying that she
was going to do so for as a direct
result of his producing a video that was
critical of
Muhammad she was adhering to Islamic law
regarding blasphemy adhering to the
program of the organization of Islamic
cooperation which she had already had
the US sign on to at the UN and which
she obviously endorsed in these closed
door meetings with the Secretary General
of the organization of Islamic
cooperation so what we have in Hillary
Clinton as a candidate for president of
the United States is an extension of
Barack Obama's statement which I think
has to be emblazoned on it ought to be
emblazoned on every bumper sticker in
every Republican candidacy in every
state in the Union the future must not
belong to those who slander the prophet
of Islam as a matter of fact the future
must belong to those who slander the
prophet of Islam they it must
belong it must belong not in other words
to those who are spreading lies or
hatred in any legitimate sense but those
who are telling unwelcome truths
unwelcome truths that are unacceptable
to the political and media
Elites we're getting to a point where it
is very dangerous nowadays to say
certain things and this is something
that never should have happened in the
United States of America Hillary Clinton
also said in the wake of the US
accepting that resolution at the UN
resolution
1618 she said that of course well we
have the First Amendment but we should
resort to good old-fashioned public
shaming of those
who speak
hatred now look you know when I first
started doing this publicly I was taken
aback I mean I was talking about the
motives and goals of the terrorists and
then Council on American Islamic
relations or these other groups would
say you're spreading
hatred and it's only now years later
that I realized that this was a very
clever tactic because it coincides
perfectly with this they've been saying
that I spread hatred for years they got
the British government to to believe it
and they tar anybody and everybody who
speaks honestly about the Jihad threat
with the same label
and the thing is is that then when you
have these pushes to criminalize hate
speech then you see where this is
going and it suits exactly the same
agenda of the organization of Islamic
cooperation which would leave us mute
and defenseless in the face of the
advancing
Jihad and so Hillary Clinton and Barack
Obama are
demonstrably enemies of the First
Amendment and the Constitution of the
United States and the thing is is that I
think people don't realize the gravity
of this that I have said this to people
before I was speaking with a lawyer once
and he said you don't have to worry
about this there is no possibility that
the freedom of speech can be infringed
in the United
States we have the First
Amendment well have you ever seen the
First Amendment stand up and defend
itself have you ever seen the First
Amendment step up to the podium and
explain to you why it was important and
needed to be defended the first
amendment is not going to do anything
unless people are willing to stand up
and defend
it the second amendment has been hedged
all around so much so that it is
essentially a dead letter in many areas
of the country try getting a handgun for
your own self-defense in New York City
and then come back and tell me that
isn't
so the first same thing could happen to
the First Amendment and it's already
happening what Hillary Clinton was
saying when she said we need to subject
these people to good oldfashioned public
shaming it's
happening mean I'm glad that Paul
mentioned the ban actually in Britain
because it's a primary example of that
that if you speak out about Jihad Terror
in an honest fashion then you will be
stigmatized denounced
marginalized and then used to do the
same thing to other
people so you see you know I will never
appear on CNN or uh MSNBC because this
has all been done to me now this is not
personal and I'm not really waiting by
the phone to uh hear from them but this
is an example of what how this works
last month I spoke at a young Americas
Foundation conference and it was right
after Ted Cruz had declared that he was
a candidate for president and he was
also speaking there Mother Jones the
leftist rag and Media Matters and uh
the Council on American Islamic
relations and some others began to
publish these articles saying Cruz is
speaking with the hate mongering bigot
Spencer and Cruz has to cancel to show
his
Goodwill and you see now because Cruz
didn't cancel to his credit they can say
well you see Cruz has all these dodgy
associations if they are to succeed in
destroying Cruz then whoever Cruz is
standing next to they can say well you
know he with Ted Cruz and what's wrong
with Cruz well he has all these very
very unsavory associations and you see
it's just one after the other this is
the solinsky tactic you pick off you you
pick a Target you smear demonize
marginalize it freeze it out then it's
out of the way and then you do it to the
next guy and you use your last success
to do it to the next one Hillary Clinton
good oldfashioned public shaming this is
what we have in the public discourse
today and this is what Millions of
people will be voting for when they vote
for Hillary Clinton for president of the
United States voting for more of the
same what I hope that will happen is
that there will be an
alternative now Ted Cruz to his credit
did not bow to the uh pressure and did
not cancel from speaking with me but
there are many many other instances like
I say this happens to everyone and
anyone who speaks out about these issues
and the Republican party to a tremendous
degree has accepted this and acquiesced
to it and so you have the spectacle of
John McCain going over to Syria and
posing for pictures with these jihadis
and coming back and saying that they're
moderates because everybody has to find
moderate Muslims everybody's Avid to
find moderate Muslims and say see these
people are the ones we can trust and
everything's
okay the thing is is that there
certainly are modate Muslims in other
words Muslims who are not interested in
beheading us or in asserting political
Supremacy in hegemony and destroying the
American system and imposing Islamic law
there are millions of such Muslims the
thing is is that there were millions of
Germans who were not Nazis there were
millions of Russians who were not Soviet
Communists but they did not do anything
and in and for many reasons they were
not able to do anything to stand up
against
the people who were the organized and
energized Vanguard and that's what we
have
today the Republican party needs to
understand that this whole thing has
been a tremendously successful
propaganda initiative from the beginning
going on for years now and that to speak
honestly about the Jihad threat to say
there are teachings within Islam of
warfare and subjugation and hem this is
not bigotry or hatred this is just the
truth these things are demonstrable from
the Quran I'll give you an example I was
talking earlier to uh Dr Weiner and we
were talking about the Muffy of Egypt
did you any of you see the Wall Street
Journal and the Muti of Egypt saying the
terrorists have nothing to do with Islam
and this is of course the Obama line
right is the Isis has nothing to do with
Islam uh all the terrorists have nothing
to do with Islam and the grand Muti of
Egypt sha Alam he published a piece in
the Wall Street Journal last week where
he was saying exactly that and quoting
the Quran and showing us that the
terrorists have nothing to do with
Islam now I'm telling you this because
this is an example of the kind of thing
that's done in the kind of thing that
rules the day in the public discourse
today the Muti of Egypt in his peace he
quoted CH 5:32 of the Quran which is
every president and every prime minister
and every Western Leader's favorite
verse of the Quran and it
says he
who saves a life shall be as if he had
given life to all mankind and he who
slays a soul shall be as if he had slain
all mankind but I only read part of
it it sounds nice doesn't it you kill
one person it's as if you've killed all
mankind you save one person it's as if
you saved all mankind and the Muti
quoted it like like that and gave us the
impression he actually said this
straight out that see this killing is
not allowed no violence is not allowed
in Islam there nothing to do with
Islam great the thing is there's
more this is actually a passage that is
taken from the talmud it's one of the uh
Jewish influences on the Quran there are
many things in the Quran that are taken
from Judaism and Christianity and
Zoroastrianism and this one comes from
the talmud and that part about saving
one person is like Saving All Mankind
and killing one person is like killing
all mankind that's the part from the
talet but this is actually how it goes
in the Quran therefore we ordained for
the children of Israel so in the first
place note this is not a universal
command to all people Allah is saying in
the Quran this is something he told the
children of Israel only so in the first
place it's restricted it's not for the
Muslims we ordained for the children of
Israel that he who Ked kills a soul
unless it be for murder or spreading
Mischief on Earth shall be as if he had
slain all
mankind now stay with me here he who
slays a soul unless it be for murder or
spreading Mischief on Earth shall be as
if he had slain All Mankind and he who
saves a life shall be as if he had given
life to all mankind okay this is what
Allah told the children of Israel and
then it goes on indeed again and again
did our Messengers come to them with
clear directives yet many of them
contined to commit excesses on Earth so
so the whole passage and that's we're
not even finished yet the whole passage
as I have read to you so far it's
actually saying Allah is saying we told
the Jews not to kill innocent people and
yet they still continue to commit
excesses on Earth so this is actually a
passage about how terrible the Jews are
of which there are many in the
Quran then there's more those who wage
war against Allah and his messenger and
go about on the earth spreading Mischief
now did you hear that go about on the
earth spreading mischief
in the in the part about killing all
mankind it says he who slays a soul
unless it be for murder or spreading
Mischief on
Earth Mischief is is fitna in Arabic
it's a very important con Concept in
Islam it's causing trouble essentially
making a disturbance in some way that is
against Islam and it'll get you killed
and so it's the first part saying we
told the Jews that anybody who kills
somebody unless he's spreading fitna
is like you've killed all of mankind and
they still did it and so therefore those
who wage war against Allah and his
messenger and go about on Earth
spreading Mischief fitna what happens to
them their recompense is that they
either be killed or crucified or have
their hands and feet cut off on opposite
sides how
peaceful so you see the whole point is
the whole passage is saying I told the
Jews this they didn't do it and so they
should be killed or crucified or have
their hands and feet cut off on opposite
Sid
the Muti only quoted the good parts that
made it seem as if there's peace taught
in Islam and the terrorists are
transgressing now what is that is that
reform is that a new vision of Islam
that's compatible with Humane values and
the human rights and the Dignity of
every human person unfortunately not
that is deception which is also an
Islamic concept of deceiving unbelievers
into complacency because a complacent
enemy is easier to beat than one that is
informed and
Resolute when Barack Obama says the
Islamic state is not
Islamic and Hillary Clinton arrests and
prosecutes somebody for criticizing
Islam and they are doing this in
cooperation with an organized group of
multinational group a Muslim group that
is determined to destroy the freedom of
speech in the United States
and when these patently deceptive
presentations are in there it's not just
the Muff te you know practically every
day I see another article coming down
you can be sure CNN NB MSNBC all of them
whenever they have a piece about is is
Islam responsible for terrorism you can
be sure the answer is no does Islam
teach anything that's violent oh no no
no when we see all these things they are
all in service all going in One
Direction and that one direction is to
make it imposs possible it's either too
much of a stigma that people don't want
to Bear they're afraid to be called
bigots and racists and hate mongers and
not get invited to the good parties and
excoriated everywhere and banned from
Britain that or it will be an absolute
criminal
offense to say these things which is
what the OIC ultimately wants and we're
already on the way you know with hate
crimes we already have hate crimes now
in the United States what's the
difference between a crime and a hate
crime
well if I come up and knock you down and
take your money that's a crime but if I
come and knock you down and take your
money and call you a dirty Californian
that's a hate crime because I hate
Californians so another words the
difference between a crime and a hate
crime is speech and so we already have
hate speech in the United States and
when the OIC and care and all these
groups in the United States are saying
that it is an act of hate to speak
honestly about the Islamic Jihad agenda
that's very
Insidious it is an ultimate ultimately
an attempt to make it impossible for us
to resist Jihad
Terror and it works it works very well
there was a few years back there was a
plot at uh Fort
Dicks there were a group of Muslims and
they were incidentally uh albanians so
they were white guys this is important
for the story stay with me they were
going to go into Fort Dicks and shoot as
many American soldiers as possible
before they themselves were killed and
then they get the 72
virgins they their plot was
foiled and their plot was foiled by a
young man named Brian Morgan Stern who
worked in a video store near Fort Dicks
and what as it happened these jihadis
they loved blood and gore they loved
death as the jihadis often boast about
doing they love death and destruction
and so they liked to watch beheading
videos and things blowing up and such
but they had them on VHS tapes so they
took them to the video store and they
said to this kid Brian they said can you
please transfer these to
DVD and he said okay and he's doing his
job and he's seeing it all go by and he
starts to get
alarmed and so he went to his manager
and he said dude
I'm seeing some really weird stuff on
these
videos it's like freaking me
out should I go to the police or would
that be
racist now remember he had seen the guys
they'd come into the store and he saw
that they were white guys albanians but
he still got it internalized it's part
of his thinking he knows it he grew up
with it he breathed it
in that it's racist to resist Jihad
Terror it's racist to try to stop
somebody from killing people in the name
of
Allah now
luckily he decided to be racist and he
went to the police and he got and the
plot was foiled and those guys are in
jail now and so we can thank him for
that but the fact that it was a close
call I think is very telling about where
we are as a
society
and is it's a testimony to the
extraordinary SU uccess of this ongoing
concerted campaign to make it impossible
to speak about these issues in any
honest
fashion and of course the stakes
couldn't be higher it's a matter of life
and death just uh today the is yesterday
rather the Islamic state issued new
videos boasting about how they were
going to be striking in the United
States it would be bigger than
911 and you know I think that we should
pay careful attention to that and take
that seriously there was recently a
young man rahil Mah Ida uh his real name
is Christopher Lee Corel Cornell and uh
he became a Muslim and insists now on
being called rahil Mah Ida and you can
see why he would want to and uh
anyway he was arrested recently for his
involvement in a Jihad plot and he said
uh he was in Columbus Ohio and he said
we in Ohio we're in every state and
we're far more organized than you think
now maybe it was an empty boast but the
fact is we see young Muslims all around
the world going to join the Islamic
State we never saw this before with
Al-Qaeda with Boh Haram with Ash shabab
with any of the other Jihad groups we
never saw it 25,000 Muslims now from
around the world have joined the Islamic
State either in Iraq or Syria or in
Libya the Islamic state has gained the
allegiance of jihadis in the Philippines
in Nigeria in
Afghanistan elsewhere in Sinai all over
the world because they claim to
reconstitute the caliphate which is in
Islamic theology the sole government to
which any Muslim really owes
obedience and this claim obviously
resonates it resonates with young
Muslims in Ohio like raahil
Maha
Chris
it resonates with all the thousands of
Muslims who've gone to join the Islamic
State and the many more who want to it
resonates with the Muslims we see
practically every day if you read
jihadwatch.org on your website on the on
the web if you read these things you
will see every day practically we see
another Muslim arrested for another
Jihad plot owing pledging allegiance to
the Islamic State all over the place
it's clearly resonating the Islamic
State's message with young Muslims
around the world at a time when all of
the western Elites all of the western
intelligencia all the media are saying
it has nothing to do with Islam this is
a dangerous and suicidal path and we
have to stand up now and say enough and
any presidential candidate that we back
and any candidate on the local State
national level we have to insist from
them that they will no longer engage in
these politically correct willful
deceptions and willful ignorance about
this problem but we'll speak about it
honestly and deal with it in a fashion
that will actually do something to
neutralize it the stakes are very high
and the time is very short and so I
would exhort all of you if you have any
contacts with political candidates with
political officials that you begin to
bring this message to them and to insist
on them the whole truth and nothing but
the truth thank you very
much thank you Mike and thank you Robert
um you mentioned the Wall Street Journal
article chrisan Ali had a full- page
article in the Wall Street Journal uh
touting her new book and calling for a
Reformation in Islam coincidentally the
president of uh Egypt has called for a
revolution in
Islam um and and her sonali in her
article talked about five discrete steps
that were necessary for the Believers to
adopt now given what you've said about
the difficulty what do you think of the
probability and the or the possibility
possibility and probability of any Step
at revolution in Islam to bring it more
in conformance with Western societal
beliefs I would never say that something
is impossible history is full of
surprises and things that people never
expected and it may be that the pressure
upon
Islam uh did you see Rocky 2 you
remember the one the remat
where they both fall to the ground and
then they're both being counted out and
the one who's going to win is the one
who can get up in
time that's kind of like the situation
that we're in now the Western world is
in Desperate Straits but so is the
Islamic world and it may be that the
pressures upon the Islamic world will be
so great that reform will become
something that's a viable possibility
but at this point it is not and with all
respect to H Ali whom I admire greatly
and to aisi the president of Egypt
uh the possibilities of these things
that here Ali enumerated being
implemented are exactly zero uh the fact
is that when you have a religion in
which it is taught that it is a perfect
religion and it is taught this in an
explicit fashion that uh it's in the
it's in the Quran in the Islamic
traditions this day I have perfected
your religion for you Allah says to
Muhammad it's perfect so you can't
reform what's perfect
and there has never been reform in Islam
except to go back to the basics which is
what reformers always do right they go
back to the originals and so there was a
reform movement in Islam where they went
back to what the Quran said and what the
Hadith said which is what aisi said to
do now I know aisi had to tread very
delicately because he's in Egypt and the
situation there is that he cannot afford
to antagonize Muslims he'll be driven
from Power immediately but the fact is
he says we'll go back to the original
Quran and Hadith that was done Muhammad
IB Abdul wahab did that you ever heard
of the
wahhabis Muhammad IB Abdul wahab died in
1792 and his whole program was getting
back to the basics back to the Quran
back to the Hadith and he created a form
of Islam that's more violent and virent
and unyielding than the rest because
that's what's in the Quran and the
hadiths so you know I wish them well and
I hope that there will be reform I do
not see it on the horizon at this point
well if you're talking about the the
question was shouldn't the word be
revolution instead of Reform if you're
talking about uh something that would
really change yeah change Islam it would
be revolution it would be a rejection of
quranic literalism a rejection of any
understanding of the Quran or other or
the example of Muhammad as being
something that should be literally
followed and that would that would
require a revolution yes my great great
friend the the late Tash bed who some of
you may have known he was honest about
that he was a a secular Muslim and he
said we have to reevaluate Muhammad as
an example and reevaluate the Quran as
being something that should be taken
literally at all times and this was he
was a real
reformer not these people who say that
there's no problem and they lie to you
about what's actually in the book like
the Muti right anyway oh yes there's a
microphone going around yes sir Robert a
two-part question please one you
mentioned all these Islamic groups and
all these different countries do you
think Isis is here to stay long term and
the second part is why do you think
Obama only speaks of isil and never of
Isis well you know in point of fact the
name of the group that they use is the
Islamic State that's their name they on
June 29th 2014 they declared themselves
to be the new caliphate and they dropped
the second half of their name was the
and that was of Iraq and shams Shams is
the lent which is the Mediterranean area
of the Middle East Syria Israel Jordan
Etc
and they dropped it so really the name
of the group if you want to call them by
what they call themselves which I'm all
for is the Islamic State it's neither
Isis nor isil but why the president when
everybody else in the world is calling
them Isis is calling them isil the only
thing I can guess is that he is subtly
emphasizing that Israel is included in
their uh
uh perview because the Syria see a lot
of times the the S and Isis is
translated as Syria which is wrong the
word is Shams which is Syria but it's
also Israel and Lebanon and Jordan and
so when he says the L he's emphasizing
that right here Robert yes
sir God bless you my friend thank you
you too I I just wanted to find out
because you know so much more about
Islam than I do
I view Islam not at all as a legitimate
religion I see it as a criminalized
sociopathy since it's Inception could
you set me right as why it should be
viewed a legitimate real religion well I
guess it depends on what your definition
of a legitimate religion is I guess I
should say that as if I was Bill Clinton
it all depends on what your definition
of legitimized
religion because
see a religion purports to to relate
human beings to the Divine Islam does
purport to relate human beings to the
Divine so by that definition it's a
religion is it also an organized
sociopathy yeah
sure uh sociopathy absolutely it's a
it's a
um is it a religion that teaches
violence and subjugation and hatred
absolutely the Quran is very clear about
that Muhammad is the Apostle of Allah
those who follow him are merciful to one
another but ruthless to the unbelievers
you can look it up in your Quran open
them to chapter 48: 29 you'll see it but
anyway that's an organized organized
sociopathy especially when you have the
command to make war against those
unbelievers which you do have in the
Quran but it's also a religion it's both
and not either or yes sir right here
right here oh where sorry I thought you
had it I actually forgot it existed yes
there's the microphone questions here up
the the lady in red and then this Gary
the lady in Black the lady in red okay
lady
W I'll be meeting her later hello yes I
was wondering what you thought in the
wake of Charlie hebo the future was for
London and the UK and
Europe uh well do you remember here's
actually this is the day to reference
Rocky um do you remember Rocky
3 where Mr T is playing the mean nasty
aggressive boxer and they say what's
your prediction for the fight and he
says my prediction
pain that's what I think is of the
future for England and Europe in general
is pain uh in all seriousness the uh
situation is very dire there they are in
an aggressively appeasement aggressive
appeasement mode the Cameron government
is uh doing everything it can I mean you
know Paul mentioned that they let in
Sheik Muhammad Al arifi when they banned
right when they banned Pamela Geller and
me and and that he had he was in favor
of violent Jihad but apparently that's
not something that is not conducive to
the public good apparently you know I
was actually banned interestingly enough
the home office they sent me this letter
and it was kind of it was kind of
exciting to get a letter from the home
office until I read it but um it said
you're being banned from the country
because you said Islam has a doctrine of
warfare and subjugation of unbelievers J
and I thought that's like being banned
for saying that the sky is blue it is
that's like being banned for saying
automobiles run on gasoline it is so a
petrol and
so the the idea that I would be banned
for saying that but alari would be led
in for saying Jihad is tearing the
infidels limb from limb and smashing
skulls it's clear the British government
under the Tories
is okay with you saying that Islam has a
doctrine of violence as long as you're
for it as long as you want the violence
to happen if you're against it then
you're not allowed in now that's a very
very uh dangerous situation because of
course they're going to lose now to
labor and labor is even
worse and so the uh UK is is bringing in
all these jihadis they are bending over
backwards to appease them what on how is
this going to work out their birth rates
are far lower than those of the Muslims
and they're already aggressive Muslim
groups saying they're going to take over
what do they where do they think they're
going to be in 20 years
and it's the same thing I it's not that
I think that Britain is finished
necessarily or that Europe is either but
I don't see any way out of this at this
point without violence that there are
going to be some British people who will
say no I'm not going to live in a Sharia
Britain and they will fight and then
Muslims will fight them and there will
be civil war I hope I'm wrong about that
but I don't I don't see any way to avoid
it at this point given the fact that
there is no government no politician no
party that is standing up and saying
we're going to confront this issue
headon not even
ukip yes ma'am hi first of all thank you
so much I hope you're speaking at a lot
of colleges and universities because I
think kids will relate to your humor and
I they it really is needed um but my
question usually they just I'm happy if
they don't throw anything uh that's okay
too as long as they're there but since I
am somewhat of an activist have you
given this same
broader uh to members of Congress and if
you have have they forgotten and should
you do it again perhaps and really I'll
speak to members of Congress anytime
they call me but here again I ain't
waiting by the phone I have never given
this talk to members of Congress
actually never spoken to members of
Congress so is that something that could
be sponsored perhaps if anybody wanted
to do it but see this is this is what
happens see I am on the list I'm a hate
group according to the Southern Poverty
Law Center and I I know I've been
putting on weight but to call me a group
is
anyway the thing
is that is taken seriously you know
people the Southern Poverty Law Center
we all know it's a it's a hate group
itself a far-left group devoted to
stigmatizing and uh ruling out of the
political discourse any political views
other than its own and yet you read you
know uh when when the thing happened
with Cruz and me and I'm reading all
these articles in the in AP and Reuters
and they're saying Cruz is going to
speak with this far right extremist
bigot the Southern Poverty Law Center
says he's a hate group and
uh counil on American Islamic relations
which is always quoted in mainstream
media but never identified as being a
supporter of Hamas being linked to Hamas
having various of its officials arrested
and convicted for Jihad Terror offenses
they never mention that but they say
this Council on American Islamic
relations says Spencer is an extremist
well I think the Hamas group is an
extremist but the fact is that they own
the mainstream and so see a congressman
is not going to meet me publicly because
then care will make a fuss and Media
Matters will make a fuss and it'll be
this blot on the congressman's record
and this is why they do what they do see
and it
works Robert um here oh
hello what I'm on hi what I'm taking
away from this is that America and
Western societies
are going to be in an endless War or
conflict with
Islam unless you see some other outcome
no I think you're right I uh think that
as long as people believe the Quran is
the word of God and as long as people
believe Muhammad is his Prophet they
will think that it's part of their
responsibility before God to wage war
against and kill unbelievers and
subjugate those they don't kill this is
Islamic Doctrine this is not something
that just a Time minority of extremists
hold to every place that Muslims have
gone in the world there has been
conflict between Muslims and non-muslims
and attempts by Muslims to impose
Islamic law every last place in history
why does the United States think it's
going to be different think it's going
to be exempt from this oh because we'll
give them
jobs can you imagine can you imagine see
I I think it's it's it's sort of strange
how maybe not so strange how the left
seems to have no understanding that
human beings have a
soul and that the soul longs to be
involved in something that matters and
not just watch movies and eat popcorn
all day and so it's astonishing to me
that they think that these jihadis who
think they're wrong but they think that
they're doing a noble work for God they
think they're doing a
grand extraordinary spiritual and and
and material effort that is the greatest
thing you can do on this Earth and that
they'll give it up to be a greeter at
Walmart or to say you want fries with
that they don't understand that that
these these people would find that to be
Inc commensurate with the dignity that
they have found being
jihadis but that just doesn't mean
anything I guess to aggressive
secularists so anyway yes I think that
it is a conflict that will exist as long
as Islam exists and I don't see Islam
going anywhere and that the only thing
we can do is be strong not just
militarily but culturally spiritually
societally standing up for our own
values and defending them imagine how
different the world would be today if we
had gone into Iraq in Afghanistan and
said instead of installing Sharia
Islamic law in constitutions in both
countries which is what we did instead
of doing that if we had said okay now we
are here and we have these bases anybody
who wants to leave Islam
come and we will give you safe harbor
cuz Islam has a death penalty for those
who leave Islam women who were beaten
and want a safe place come and will
protect
you people who speak out and they say
things that they're that that are
considered to be Blasphemous or whatever
will give you
protection do you think anybody would
have
come and do you think that we might have
been able to build a real good solid
base of support among Muslims who don't
want to live under Islamic law but don't
have any place to go
but we didn't do that we lost the
opportunity you know in India remember
that famous old story about when the
British Raj was at its height they had
this cultural confidence I'm speaking
about the British Raj had taken over
India and the Hindus were performing
Sati the practice of having the wife of
the man who had just died throw herself
onto the funeral py of her
husband and the British outlawed it and
the Hindu delegation went to the British
and said well you know that's our
culture and the British Authority in
charge he said oh you have your culture
well very well we have to respect your
culture but we have our own culture so
you go ahead and perform Sati because
that's your culture and then we will
live by our culture which is anybody who
performs Sati we will hang by the neck
until
dead you have your culture and we have
ours and so Sati
ended this is the kind of cultural
confidence we should have had coming
into Iraq and Afghanistan in Japan
Douglas MacArthur with the occupying
force in 1945 to 53 he mandated that
Shinto the the the religious ideology
that had given rise to the war would
have no place in the schools or in the
uh political
system it was decreed what if we had
gone into an irq and Afghanistan and
said no islamists nobody who is a
supporter of Shar nobody who believes in
political Islam will will have no place
in the schools or in the government well
maybe they wouldn't have had anybody in
the
government but I think it would have
been far more in keeping with our own
principles as a nation to have done that
than to have done what we did and
installed Islamic law yes ma'am ah the
lady in red yes uh hello my fear and I'm
certain I'm not alone is that at some
point uh the beliefs of the Iranians and
Isel will couple
God forbid couple in other words work
together uh but my real question is how
important is the belief that the former
ambassador of of uh Iran said that they
await the the reappearance of the 12th
Iman but it will only happen after great
disasters this is very important is it
important to the general mus
jihadists that belief no uh I'll explain
everything
um in the first place will the Islamic
State and Iran join forces that's
unlikely because they hate each other
it's possible because there's an old
saying in Arabic that translates to my
brother against my brother but both of
us against our cousin and that could
happen but it's very unlikely because
you've got the Sunni Shiite divide there
which is400 years old they hate each
other
they don't generally make common cause
and the Islamic state is directly
threatening the Shiite client state in
Baghdad that the Iranians want to
keep the Iraqi state that the Iraqi
government that we installed there and
so I don't see that happening in in in
the foreseeable future at least uh as
far as the 12th Imam goes in in in
Shiite Islam Shiite Islam is only 10 to
15% of Muslims worldwide and in Shiite
Islam the successor of Muhammad as the
leader of the Islamic community has to
be a member of his household and so it
was a hereditary office like a king and
the last Imam the 12th 12 or shiism is
the official religion of the Islamic
Republic of Iran in the year 874 he was
5 years old but he was the Imam because
it was hereditary he fell down a well
and
died but there were some people around
him who did not want to give up power
and so they started to claim
and they succeeded that he was actually
still alive and he had gone into
occultation into hiding and that he was
giving them
messages and he's still down there in
the well Mak akad actually had a super
highway built between the well and K and
tan so that he could go talk to the 12th
Imam in the well and that when the 12th
Imam comes out he can get right to ton
and they can start get down to business
so they take this very seriously but the
story is that yes at a time when the
Muslims are persecuted more fiercely
than they've ever been before then the
12th Imam will come out of the well and
then he will conquer and islamize the
world and kill all the enemies of Islam
which is
us the thing about that is is that there
have been mullah in Iran who have said
that they could trigger that happening
by triggering the persecution say nuking
Tel Aviv and then having Retaliator then
receiving retaliatory nuclear fire that
would kill 10 to 15 million Iranians
which would mean the Muslims are
persecuted more fiercely than they've
ever been before and then the 12th Imam
will come
back and so it's a very very dangerous
idea because you remember mutually
assured destruction with the Soviet
Union neither of us wanted to die and so
we didn't kill each
other and with these people that doesn't
work cuz they want to
die and so it's very difficult to deal
with but we know that ultimately life
does conquer death and we are the
standing on the side of life and so we
will ultimately Prevail in this but as
far as the thing goes with the the
Shiites most Muslims don't believe that
85 to 90% of the Muslims are sunnis and
they don't buy any of that but still the
Iranians might act upon it right here
okay last one no Pat I Pat two more I'll
try to be briefer in my answers Pat
and what I like to know I heard exactly
what you
said especially now
but I have a
[Music]
question you know you know doctor you
heard of Dr Willam Reich oh yes I've
heard of him Reich he was a disciple of
roid and he wrote a book called the mass
psychology of
fascism and mass psychology means not
only fascist there's aish in every yeah
like the religions that are tolerant
like Christian or Jewish or Buddhist
it's okay but there are some religions
that are intolerant
totalitarian and in that case what would
what happened with Hitler what happened
with musolini what happened with with
the to Tojo in Japan is the complete
annihilation of those people who are
intolerant and dictatorial so what you
have to say about that well you're
talking about a an authoritarian
dictatorial religious system absolutely
that's exactly what we have and it is uh
there are many many resonances with
fascism that it does share yes as far as
uh complete Annihilation I would be all
for the annihilation of the belief
system but even that is is very
difficult and when it comes to human
beings you know obviously I'm in favor
of the universal Dignity of all people
and human rights and so on so I hope we
would be able to find some way to fight
this that would not involve killing
people now maybe that's completely
unrealistic but uh uh and you know there
are Wars and Wars will come and Wars
will go and so if it may be that this
will come to a war that is strictly a
war between Muslims and non-muslims I
mean this could happen because the
Muslims are Waging War in the name of
Islam and saying that they are fighting
because of Islam and the West is busy
saying no no no this has nothing to do
with Islam and bringing more Muslims in
ultimately there's going to be conflict
about this and either the Muslims are
going to have to saying stop saying that
they're at war with the west or the West
will surrender or the West will fight
and uh if there if it comes to that I
hope it doesn't then I hope that we will
prevail and actually I'm confident that
we will because as I say life always
ultimately wins out over death and those
who say they love death when they say we
will defeat you because we love death
more than you love life they will never
defeat us on that basis life will always
Prevail and maybe that's an
eschatological hope or a Airy mysticism
but I do believe it very strongly and I
think that the history of uh human
history in general and the history of
warfare Bears out that states that were
authoritarian totalitarian and life-
destroying generally did not Prevail in
the long run last question last question
Mr Boon thank you for being here oh
thank you just a quick positive remark
about what you just said and then a
question and and that is that light is
greater than Darkness Darkness cannot
exist
with light and if we continue to speak
up as you are and as others are and we
continue to spread the light of truth
then the darkness will be exposed and I
believe we can win it is love it is life
but it is light which is truth
absolutely and so we've got to keep
proclaiming the truth even though it's
illegal uh in the Quran but and because
it's illegal now I just want to ask you
a question should we attach any
significance to the fact that um
President Obama's closest adviser as he
has said many times and Hillary
Clinton's closest advisor are both
Iranian uh Hillary Clinton's closest
adviser actually is
Saudi uh if you're talking about Aben
yeah that Weiner's wife the other weener
the the bad wiener yeah
uh yeah Mike's cousin yeah uh anyway um
Huma abdin is Saudi Valerie Jarrett is
uh Iranian and
uh I do think that there is something to
that I mean obviously we may never know
ultimately but there's no doubt that the
president has pursued
simultaneously a foreign policy that is
in line with uh uh doing everything that
the Saudis want and everything the
Iranians want now these two things are
very curious because they're on a
collision course ultimately the Saudis
and Iranians are Rivals because of the
sunite Divide they're not friends and so
I don't know how that's all going to
resolve but I think that it's
unmistakable that the president has
pursued those policies and then you look
at these advisers and you got to think
well maybe they've been giving advice
and it's been
heated everything that the president has
done has been in line with the Islamic
agenda and people say well he killed Bin
Laden he killed alaki well in the first
place those things were in motion before
he became president and second it's very
clear that he is against violent Jihad
but he's done everything he could to Aid
and ab bet the gold of the jihadis which
was the implementation of Islamic law in
every place where it could be
implemented so he is more of the Muslim
Brotherhood type which wants to
implement the Islamic law by peaceful
means winning elections and so on and
then with the Iranians he's been
appeasing and appeasing and appeasing
and uh acquiescing to this disastrous
deal that uh as Benjamin Netanyahu is so
articulately and eloquently stated
there's a Statesman if only he could run
for president in
16 so in in in other words I think the
record is very clear it cannot be
directly attributed to these advisers
because well the nature of an adviser is
he doesn't get credit for what he
advises if it's implemented but uh
certainly the trajectories are
unmistakable
thank you Robert thank you very much
[Applause]